earlier this year evil geniuses enlisted
the services of stewie2k malik and two
other members of cloud9's fabled major
winning core to by their own admission
save nacs
the thing is
it isn't going very well
in fact it is nothing short of an
absolute disaster the question that us
north american copium addicted
counter-strike stands are struggling
with
is why
and
what's gonna happen as a result
[Music]
okay so before we dive in i must humbly
ask that you like the video subscribe to
the channel and turn on notifications we
are super close to 2 million subs and
you yes you can help us get there but
more importantly please
all of you just give all of your energy
to eg they just they need it more than
we do right now
thank you was that too sad i hope it
wasn't too sad okay so if you have been
paying any amount of attention to the
american rmr for the upcoming pgl major
in antwerp then you may have noticed
that north american counter-strike is
once again look i'm not going to say
dead because that is just a meme at this
point i won't even say it's down
horrendous cause it's not but it is down
fairly bad for starters those beautiful
bat-shit crazy brazilians on furia
continue to be the best team in north
america which is neither surprising nor
troublesome if you ask me we stan our
lord and savior art in this house and
kneel at the feet of all of his
bison-rushing [ __ ] alright the man
is a god what is troublesome is the fact
that both complexity and liquid only
managed to finish fourth and fifth
respectively meaning that both rosters
fell
a little too close for comfort to not
even securing contender status now to be
fair they did make the major and that's
what's important
and while i don't really think there was
a chance that they wouldn't
for the scrappy stickers scraping
youngans on complexity in particular
it was lovely to see a bomb tap forces
his hand he peeks outwards does damage
but dies and complexity will be the
first north american representative at
the antwerp major they've done it long
have we waited to be blessed with grim
stickers
and oh baby am i ready to slap one on
was it somewhat surprising that
complexity and especially liquid lost
out to both mibr and imperial esports
i.e fallen's last dance roster
for challenger status i mean yeah kinda
like i know these these teams are new
and they're still synergizing and stuff
but like that's that's a little rattling
for n.a fans don't you think but what
was really rattling for n a fans was
evil geniuses
not making it at all as i'm sure most of
you are well aware evil geniuses entered
2022 hungrier than ever to re-establish
themselves as a juggernaut not only in
north american counter-strike but
all of counter-strike after exiting the
stockholm major in november as the
default 0-3 on everyone's pickums eg set
out to build a veritable super team they
snagged stewie rush and automatic placed
them alongside cirque and breeze and put
all of them under the guidance of
legendary french coach malik i won't go
over all of it again since i did a
donate me about their formation back in
january but be sure to check it out if
you want a deeper dive on how this
roster came to be the hope is that with
stewie igling malik overseeing
everything and again such clearly
defined roles something which liquid
went a long time without having
this roster will have synergy and a
sense of direction from the get-go yeah
um
oops suffice it to say no one really
knew whether this lineup would be great
or not even i a long time die hard eg
fan who hyped up this roster a fair bit
had no idea whether they'd actually be
able to deliver with stewie as the sole
dedicated igl rush having been off for
like six months and tim having spent
like an entire year playing valorant
no one knew what to expect but i think
it's safe to say
that no one expected them to be this
bad
since the start of 2022 eg's tournament
results have been
unspeakably subpar getting too oned by
big at blast premiere is one thing
losing to the fragadelfia winning strife
esports in the open qualifier of the
antwerp major is another thing entirely
the issue is that since then
their results have
basically worsened they ended up making
the american rmr in the next round of
opens but only after narrowly securing
second following a fairly one-sided loss
to party astronauts now the rest of
party astronaut shows up
standing
ready oh dear rush gets pulled out and
this is only cirque left he gets fragged
and there you have it that's party
astronauts coming in with the defuse
disappearing off the server
they proceeded to exit the group stages
of esl pro league season 15 without
securing a single
win
unbelievably lucky not to get caught the
money's going to force him wide
against the second is happening again
i thought that was easy
for a second
that was bonkers no it's all under the
clutch
alan it all comes down to breeze
he's already found two he needs two more
and he's not even gonna get around the
corner there we go ago have done it have
won it they're moving up in the group
evil geniuses will finish here without a
series win but the straw that broke the
camel's back came this past weekend with
a genuinely staggering loss to
argentinian organization 9z that
resulted in evil geniuses placing eighth
that's right you heard me eighth in the
american rmr for the antwerp major he
will remove max back to the 2v2 with 24
seconds light breeze goes into the site
commits to the plan cgt is moving
forward
eg are not going to the manager it
is still alive oh the celebration you
can see what that means and while it was
very lovely to watch 9z go on to beat
payne and achieve their hopes and dreams
in making the major as far as eg were
concerned
this was in stu's own words
rock bottom at this point no one had any
words to describe any of this well
that's not true they did they were just
sparse and
sad whatever grievances may or may not
persist between some of north america's
finest it's safe to say that nobody not
even rivals ex-teammates etc wants to
see an already floundering region lose
out on a super team this horrifically so
what does the spell for the future of
evil geniuses and the superstars who don
their flag is stewie quitting cs to
become a full-time valerante streamer
like his boy tariq while i obviously
can't say for certain
judging by his tweets and what he's said
in the past
it seems very unlikely people are quick
to forget just how resilient this
[ __ ] really is and how hard he
had to work to get where he is today
this dude is a born competitor he's won
a major a slam and some and if you ask
me there's no way he doesn't go out on
top as for where eg go from here
it is definitely fair to call this rock
bottom like look i remain a huge fan of
this roster and do genuinely think that
they still have tons of potential
i just have no idea how they go about
accessing it what i do know is that it
pretty much can't get any worse from
here
the worst has come
it happened you don't need to worry
about it anymore the eg guys realize
this of course i repeat they realize
this stop flaming them on social media
because you lost a bet it's very cringe
and can start rebuilding from the ground
up with a nothing to lose attitude it's
still too early to start talking about
roster changes in my opinion since
disastrous as the results have been
it has only been four months and i do
continue to hold out hope that this
roster is capable of great things the
only real question mark going into this
was tim and i think it's fair to say
that he's honestly performing
really well stewie is stewie rush at his
best was one of the most selfless
sacrificial entries in the world
cirque was arguably the best opera in
north america for quite some time and
breeze is just cracked on paper i still
think this roster
bangs
in practice
we'll just have to wait and see
i for one am not quite ready to call a
time of death just yet and for all of
our sakes
i hope you're not as well
it's incredible it's unbelievable the
whole joke is that he's the two majors
both brazil's majors were one with him
so the joke the meme is no fnx no major
the community's having a ball with it
because they're like oh he's playing for
his his 100 win rate at the majors